Didn't you also do some work for Steven
Spewer?
>> I was on X camera. We were doing scenes
where Jude Law was being pulled up out
of the hovercraft or whatever he was in
pulling focus on him pulling away from
the camera up into the sky on wires.
Spent 6 weeks in Las Vegas on a movie
once, a Kirsten Dunce movie. A colleague
of mine, he worked on some big horror
movie. Something was going wrong on the
set like things were bad things were
happening. People were getting hurt.
They actually brought a priest in to
exercise something out of the film set
and to try to protect the crew. I was a
bottom feeder, but I wanted your job
>> in Hollywood.
>> Hollywood. Yeah.
>> In Hollywood.
>> Yeah. No, that's like Yeah, there is
sort of a a hierarchy there. You know,
there's a ladder for sure. But I I was
actually lower than you originally cuz I
did radio.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Okay.
>> So, I was in radio when I was like 14 to
like 20. So, that's like the lowest rung
in the entertainment industry is radio.
So,
>> so I worked a lot in reality television.
I know you worked in actual cinema.
We're going to talk about this.
>> Yeah. Scripted stuff.
>> Scripted stuff. What kind of movies did
you work on?
>> Oh, I I started actually kickboxing
action movies were kind of like what I
really started.
>> Yeah.
>> Kickboxing action movies. That's like
>> the one It was the heyday of the $1.3
million movie. It's like if you had a
market to go to and you could you could
budget it out like I'm going to make to
this market. I've got this star in it.
>> $1.3 million you can make this movie.
Crew gets this much, you know, actors
get this much and it's like and they
were just
>> cookie cutter. Yeah. were just cranking
out those $1.3 million stuff.
>> What do they call that? Like a G or
F-rated movie like
>> Well, yeah. Yeah. See B's for sure.
Yeah. Cerbs. But yeah, it was uh it was
a lot of work at that time in the 90s.
Yeah.
>> Wow. I've probably watched some of
those.
>> Yeah, I'm sure we have. There's a lot of
stars we know all did those movies too
at some point in their career as well.
>> So, what really got you into that? I
mean, did you go to film school? Like
>> No. No, I didn't go to film school. I uh
I actually I actually I actually messed
up high school so badly I couldn't get
into film school. But I I uh I basically
had a camera in my hand since I was a
kid. You know, I was using my dad's
manual camera. I was learning how to do
black and white photography. I shoot
super eight. I worked with early video
cameras when I was a kid, like in grade
school. So I was always playing with a
camera. My family, my my grandfather, my
dad on my mom's side was a mountain
photographer in New Zealand. Oh, cool.
>> You know, the late 1800s, early 19 And I
think New Zealand the place like to ride
out the end times.
>> Lord of the Rings are shot in New
Zealand, right?
>> Yes. New Zealand is probably one of my
favorite places I've ever been to ever.
>> You've shot there as well or you just
travel. Ministry reason. Yeah. Yeah. But
but beautiful. Yeah. Yeah. No, so I have
that in my background. I just had a
camera in my background. So I uh I
decided that I wanted to make movies. It
was, you know, I saw Steven Soderberg,
you know, made Sex Lives and Videotape
with a credit card and he used like real
cameras. I'm thinking like this is
possible for me.
>> So coming out of high school, I I
basically I had an opportunity to to
move to Australia and live there because
my my mom's side of the family is from
Australia, you know, from New Zealand to
Australia.
>> And I thought, you know what? I'm going
to go to Australia and I'm going to get
into the film business.
>> Yeah. Do you speak Australian?
>> I'm kidding.
>> I you know, when I was there for a
couple of months, I I had a moment where
I had to switch. I could go like I could
either go with this accent that's coming
or I could say no to the accent and I I
I fortunately sorry I said no to the
accent
>> mighty
this one's a big one.
>> Yeah. So I I I moved there when I was
just like 21 years old and I
>> I just was determined to get into the
film business
>> and
>> is there much of a film scene down
there?
>> There really wasn't at the time. There
wasn't at the time. That's a That's I
was only there for about a year.
>> Crocodile Dundee changed that.
>> Reality TV. You should have been there.
>> That's true.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, the tax I mean there was a
lot of movies made there, you know, they
built studios. Warner Brothers was there
in Brisbane and Gold Coast and Yeah. But
I never I never quite made it to that
level there at that time because there
was a downturn in the industry
>> and I was competing for for work with
like out of work cameramen. I was just
nobody. I just did one movie and I just
couldn't survive there. It wasn't enough
work. So now, where are you like
spiritually raised in the church? Like
are you
>> Yeah, I was raised in the church. I was
born a 7th Day Adventist. I was raised
as a Christian uh 16 years old. I My
parents had gotten divorced and I had an
opportunity to go live with one of them.
And I I made that decision. And at that
time, that's when I got into I was in
radio for a couple of years at 14. At
16, I left I left the church kind of I
stopped going to church. And it was the
only way to survive in the
entertainment. can't hold a job in the
entertainment business unless you're
willing to work, you know, seven days a
week at any time.
>> It is true. It is true.
>> So, that's the first kind of thing I
compromised on.
>> Yeah. Wow. We have a very similar story.
I mean, like I, you know, grew up in in
the church and then also left and then
when I got to Hollywood, it was like
working on all those days and it just
you you have this kind of dangling
carrot like I want to do this thing
really bad and it's like that's what you
have to do. You have no latitude to be
like, eh, can I have Friday night to
Sabbath off? I mean, that's when
everybody wants to party, right?
>> That's it. Yeah. So, when I started in
radio, I mean, it was it was in Barryian
Springs, so it wasn't a big deal to work
at the campus there. But, you know, when
I went to high school in Kalamazoo at
16,
>> I was working at a top 40 radio station.
I was working on an AMI talk radio kind
of talk format
>> and the only shot that I would get would
be like, you know, Friday night
overnight or something like that. So,
you know, it's like either Yeah. What
are you going to do? So,
>> yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's just, you know, I'm glad
that this is coming up right now because
um there's a lot of kids that also want
to go to Hollywood. Um you know, we have
film schools in a lot of the
universities and uh it's the one thing
that I I do caution people against just,
you know, if you're going to do this,
it's going to be difficult for you to
maintain
>> the the yeah the the the the things that
you've grown up to um value as your
belief system and those are going to get
compromised. I mean, even on the acting
side, it's even that much more. I mean,
to me, actors are compromised people
that have literally gone through a h
double hockey stick, for lack of a
better term, to compromise. And then
Yeah.
>> Yeah. No, apologies for all the actors
out there that might see this, but
that's, you know, dealing with that
world was one of the reasons I left. I
could not take it any longer. Oh, wow.
>> I mean, it was just, it was what
happens. I mean, this happens to
everybody, too, that get that finds a
certain amount of success in Hollywood.
>> It does change you.
>> Like, in what way does it change you?
>> You know what it is? I've raised kids,
so I know what it is to have a spoiled
child.
>> Cuz I've I've messed up some things,
right? So, but when you recognize a
spoiled child in an adult Yeah.
>> Yep. And you feed it
>> and you feed it.
>> You feed it with validation, but
everybody wants to be around you, give
you things. I I was always shocked to
that like I when I first moved there,
you know, I do catering jobs and I would
just like get around the industry. So, I
worked at the Oscars and all sorts of
things like that
>> and and it's amazing what they give
these people. I mean, it's like you you
have the money to buy whatever you want
and and it's like companies just shower
these people with
>> crazy gifts, cars, jewelry, jewelry,
glasses, clothes, I mean, you you name
it. It's like very expensive stuff and,
you know, bags and whatever.
>> Yeah. They want you to to do it. So, so
think of the individual that's receiving
that. All of a sudden, it's like, why
why why do I need to buy anything? So,
we used to have I remember Mike Tyson
one time I worked at a restaurant. He
came in, racked up this massive bill. I
mean, he had gobs of people there at the
restaurant and then he was like walked
out and the server had to walk out there
and be like, "What are you doing?" And
he was just like, "You you want me to
pay for this?"
>> What?
>> I was like, "Yeah,
you're at a restaurant."
>> Yeah. Oh, and did he end up paying or?
>> Yeah, cuz the server made him. But it
was just like the mentality that he had
was I mean,
>> not everyone's the same. I've worked
with some wonderful people, too. And I
just I just see that it it changes
people. It really does corrupt.
>> It does. Also, I I I have a theory.
People that are attracted to that, the
limelight or whatever like this had
something break in their in their
childhood. I think most people divorce
something traum traumatic or whatever
like that and maybe didn't get the
validation and it's like it's like a
room full of people that just crave this
validation. So they're willing to do
lengthy things to get that fame and I
think that's where a lot of the problem
happens. And then there's also a lack of
God in that industry who can really
bring you on the right path and be like,
"No, find validation in me, you know,
and God helps you to find that humility
to because your your peace and your
strength and your your contentment is in
Jesus."
>> Yeah.
>> So, like Andrew said, there is there's a
lot of wonderful people. I think all
that stuff, the money, the fame,
whatever, they're like amplifiers,
>> right?
>> Right. Whatever's there, it's just going
to magnify it. So, if you're already a
nice person,
>> you know, it's going to come out. And
you you I mean you read or hear stories
about you know people that are
celebrities they go to a restaurant they
>> they treat people really sweet or they
give them like these nice tips and it's
it's already there.
>> Yeah.
>> You know so you're going to you're going
to feed it.
>> But the reason why I got into the
business like what I wanted to do with
film making was I wanted to tell stories
because I didn't want to be on on
camera. I wanted to to be a part of
crafting the story inspire people to
inspire people because I realized, you
know, when I did some stuff back in I
did some stuff in high school and
>> I was like I had some success with that
really, you know, very early
>> and I realized the power it had
>> to capture people's imagination. You
know, there's the story that you write,
there's the story that you shoot,
there's the story that you edit. You
know, it always changes. The film
changes, but when it's released out into
the wild, every person experiences that
movie as their own
>> story, their own imagination. That's
powerful.
>> I believe that when you watch a movie,
you see that through their eyes. You are
actually watching that movie
>> through them. And that's why when you
watch immoral acts and you know people
sleeping with each other and all that
kind of stuff,
>> you are either the guy or the girl.
>> It's true. You feel like you're that
person.
>> You are that person. And and so it's
like the devil has created this device
to watch other people sin and then we
just think like, "Oh, I'm not doing
that. I'm I'm I'm the guy that's just
watching." But it is, I believe, 100%
happening inside your brain.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. Vicarious living.
>> 100%. Yeah. In Romans 1:es 29 through32,
it talks about verses 29 and 30 talk
about the, you know, the character here.
Unrighteousness, sexual morality,
wickedness, covetousness, maliciousness,
full of envy, murder, strife, deceit,
evil-mindedness, whisperers, backbiters,
all the haters of God, violent, proud,
boasters, inventors of evil things. all
of these things unloving, unforgiving,
unmerciful. And in verse 32 says,
knowing the righteous judgment of God,
that those who practice such thing are
deserving of death, not only do the
same, but right there, have pleasure in
them that do them. When we enjoy people
doing all of those things as
entertainment, we actually participate
in that sin.
>> Why Why are we wanting to see people
die? Why are we wanting to see
relationships broken up? like like those
things should be like, "Oh, I I really
feel sad that that's happened to you."
And ah, you know, it's like think of the
day and age that we live in, right? You
went to war back in whatever time before
you saw a bunch of people murdered. It's
going to mess you up in your head. I
don't know how David wasn't messed up. I
mean, other than like seriously, if
you're And their warfare is even worse.
It's like up close and personal. Like
you're feeling and hearing the guy bleed
out and gurgle and whatever. Mhm.
>> Sorry for our young viewers, but it's
like, you know, I I honestly really
truly believe that that that right
there, we live in this world where
people are watching people die all the
time and they're taking pleasure in it.
It's weird.
>> And also, we've talked about it several
times on the show, but for those who
haven't heard it yet, mirror neurons,
it's a scientific
>> aspect that basically explains that your
brain registers what you're seeing as as
if you're doing it yourself. this is
science, you know, and so it's like
you're watching somebody die or you're
watching you're sitting here with your
spouse and you're watching another
couple have sex on the screen. It's like
>> you're literally watching it as if as if
you're participating in it yourself and
it's that's when it gets really, you
know, sticky, right? Yeah. So, yeah,
there's there's um
>> it's vicarious, right? And and it's like
a child when a child we we we know okay
well we can't let you know babies or
children young children toddlers watch
these sorts of things but we don't
realize that we're actually you know
though we have a layer now that we can
say well that's not real I know that's
not true
>> but why do we still enjoy it? Why do we
get goosebumps? Why do we get aroused?
It's the same response.
>> Yeah. Why is it weird to watch that
stuff on an airplane full of a bunch of
other people?
>> But for some people it's not weird
anymore. And that's the that's the
weirdness of it. I was sitting next to
my kids and somebody was watching
something and I was just like, "Are you
kidding me?" Like,
>> when I went to Australia to get into the
film business, what I I had in my mind
to do was I called up Panavision in
Hollywood before I left. I was living in
Michigan before I went to uh to to
Australia. I mailordered a t-shirt, a
Panovision t-shirt
with the, you know, the Panovision,
>> you know, ground glass bug on the front,
Panovision on the back. Yeah.
>> And I just had a couple of those shirts
and I would just wear them around
walking around Melbourne, Australia.
>> And I walked into this store, which you
see the picture there, and you can see
it tells you exactly where I was headed.
>> What is this place?
>> Well, it says right there. I think it
says literature. It's kind of the bad
glare there.
>> Leather rubberware.
>> So, I checked it out. I was in there and
as I was leaving the manager who I who I
took the picture of there, he said,
"Hey, you work for Panavision."
I said, "No, I don't work for
Panavision, but I'm looking for a job."
>> Wow.
>> He says, "It's funny that you say that."
>> Interesting.
>> A friend of mine is a production
designer who's doing a movie, a
lowbudget kickboxing movie just down the
street in an abandoned power station and
they're looking for crew. They're just
building sets right now. If you're
interested, I'll let them know. I said,
"Yeah, here's my number."
>> Wow. And I was in on the art department.
>> Boom.
>> Building sets, painting seven days a
week,
>> 16 hours a day.
>> Yep.
>> Just almost living there for like three
months. Y
>> working for free.
>> Y
>> being part of the, you know, the
glamour.
>> She probably paid peanuts.
>> Oh man. I mean, every break that I've
had in my career in in in that business,
I mean, eventually, yes, everything was
great. I was financially very very well
off, but in the beginning, I mean,
that's that's the thing. It's like it's
a sausage factory. It's a meat grinder.
It just takes young people and just
dumps them by the bucket into a grinder
and you just crank it out and see who
lasts and who's willing to go through
it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's true. And that's why if
you have these, you know, religious
convictions going into something, it
doesn't matter. There's a hundred people
behind you who want it just as bad as
you do. And the the people at the top,
they don't care. They don't care who
that guy is that's going to fill that
role.
>> No, that's exactly it.
>> They'll just take you. I started to do
that and I said,"Well, you know, as long
I'll do all this if you give me a shot
to work on the camera crew when the
production starts."
>> Nice.
>> And they were like, "Oh yeah, we'll make
you a PA or something. You can like, you
know, plug in the director's monitor,
move cases and stuff, get coffee." And
I'm like, "Sure, I'll do it." Yeah. So,
I was working for free just to do that
later.
>> That's actually the people they're
looking for is the guy that will do
that.
>> Exactly. Because then, right just before
the show started, um, we were we were
prepping the camera gear. I was
learning, you know, they were taking me
to the camera house and, you know, like
getting my hands on real film equipment,
just, you know, learning it and just
digesting it and absorbing as much as I
could. The crew that was going to do it
because it was so low budget, some of
the guys got a commercial for like two
days and they were going to make more
money in two days than they would make
in four weeks on this show
>> because they were going to work for
almost nothing. That's how bad the the
work was there. Like people were just
working for almost nothing.
>> So they're like,
>> "We got this kid over here. M
>> maybe we can train him to load film.
>> And that's what happened.
>> Wow.
>> I loaded I started loading film and it
was a clapper loader. So this is like a
picture. There's a picture of me on my
very first movie. There's Bang in the
Slate.
>> Wow.
>> How old are you right here?
>> Uh yeah. This is 20
21.
>> Oh wow. So you were pretty young when
you went out there.
>> I was 21. Yeah.
>> You're about that age too, right Scotty?
Something like that.
>> Yes. Yeah. Very close to that.
>> Yeah.
>> So what happened next after that? So
this is your first production. You
started kind of climbing the career
ladder.
>> Yeah, I started climbing the career
ladder. I worked on some, you know,
action. There's another kickboxing
action movie I did back in the time.
John Ritter was in this movie. And John
Ritter was actually one of the nicest
actors I ever met. Very nice man.
>> That's the guy from Thre's Company.
>> Thre's Company. Yeah. So I one of the
guy, one of the many people that I
worked with that I grew up watching on
television, which was always
interesting.
>> Yeah, that is interesting.
>> Meet those people.
>> So yeah. So and over time I just worked
my way up and here I I was working on
the the TV show Chuck for NBC. Okay,
>> that's an actual HD rig. We used to they
used to shoot that show on 16
millimeter, but we shot this on HD
because there was one episode that they
did in 3D.
>> Wow.
>> They wanted a proof of concept that you
could actually shoot 3D on set without
extra post-production.
>> Oh wow.
>> Was a company 3 did this. So this is
really nerdy. Probably don't want to
have all this stuff, but it's like
>> No, it's great.
>> This is my Yeah. So I I had this
experience and then I I you know,
basically I became an operator, you
know, the last 10 years or so, 11 years
of my career, I was a camera operator.
>> Yeah. and um you know it was a very it
was a great job. So I mean I I had a I
had a dream a dream situation you know
going back to the experience that I had
um getting into the business I had to
give up the Sabbath. I later in my my
career I actually was very convicted
that I needed to go back to church. I
needed to keep the Sabbath. And I
actually started to attend church again
at one point when my career was really
slow. And
I I was I was doing okay. It was really
kind of tough, but my son got sick with
cancer.
>> Oh,
>> my first son got sick with cancer and my
insurance
uh was in danger of running out. And so
I was really struggling to, you know, to
keep my hours up and to have the
insurance that helped cover all the
medical bills and I got a job working at
the camera department part-time at uh
was it Paramount Pictures. So for me to
go from like I at this time I was not a
camera operator. I was I was a focus
puller. I was a first assistant. And I'd
already been in the business for a
number of years.
>> And then I I took this loading kind of a
camera loading job, desk job at the at
the camera department just so that I
could keep the Sabbath.
>> Oh wow.
>> So was that at Paramount?
>> That was at Paramount. Yeah.
>> So do you know where Sunset and Gower
are?
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. That was my first apartment.
>> Okay.
>> Right there.
>> That was probably the only like uh
non-gangster kid for miles
>> when I moved there. I'll be nice.
>> Yeah. So I I I did that for a while and
it was, you know, it was good. You know,
the Lord kept me okay. I was I the
insurance continued and everything was
fine. But I I got a call one night. I
did a pilot before that time. I did a
pilot for a TV show and it was supposed
to be uh it was Michael Man producing
it.
>> And you know, one of the reasons I know
that I got seduced into Hollywood was
all the stuff that I watched in the 80s
growing up. I mean, it was it was MTV,
it was Miami Vice. Especially Miami Vice
because it put storytelling with music
and it was
>> yeah cinematic. Cinematic. Yeah, they
went for the
>> very cinematic. It was a very uh it was
a watershed moment I think in television
as far as the stylistic development. And
so I was very much like interested in
working on this thing that Michael man
was going to return to television to do.
>> And so I I worked on this pilot of
course and then of course I did the
thing where I kept the Sabbath for a
while.
I get this call, you know, pilots are
shot like in March and April and then
the then the shows are picked up like
in, you know, to for production like in
July and August, right? So I I go
through this phase and I'm I'm keeping
the Sabbath and I'm working at the
studio and then I get a call on Friday
night after I'm home and it's it's the
show that I did a pilot that got picked
up. So it's going into production.
They're already shooting. It's fully
crewed, but guess what? We're adding a C
camera crew tonight last minute. we got
your name because your name was on the
on one of the uh the crew list for the
pilot and so we wanted to bring people
in from the pilot that had experience
working with the cameras, working with
Michael, all that stuff.
>> And I was like, "Oh." And also the
cameraman that was going to shoot it,
well that was shooting it was was like
one of my favorites. He shot the X-Files
and I was a big X-Files fan.
>> So this was a cameraman's cameraman.
This is like a guy that you want as a
cameraman. This was the guy you wanted
to work for
>> and he was a great boss. So I was like,
>> "We need you to come in right now.
I waited for a moment and I I said yes.
>> And that was on You mean like it was on
the Sabbath? Yeah.
>> Oh, it was Friday night. The sun had
gone down and I got the call. And but
there's so many people's careers are
made from that moment when that phone
calls I mean I started the business. We
had a pager, right? I don't know if that
was maybe you had a pager. So you you
you didn't have a cell phone. So if you
were like driving down the Santa Monica
Freeway, the 405 and the and the
traffic's everywhere.
>> You had to find a way.
>> You got to find a way off to get off.
And I've been like I I Yeah. Talking
about gangs and phone jacking. I've
trying to use pay phones with gang
members like oh man they kick you off
the phone.
>> Oh yeah.
>> That happened to me a few times because
you pull over anywhere. You pull over
anywhere to get the job.
>> Pull over in like the hood. Hello. I
want this job.
>> I know. It's Yeah. It's bad. So So I
took the job and
>> you know the rest is history. I My
career shot off like a rocket.
>> Wow.
>> I never stopped working for 14 years.
That man kept me busy for 14 years. See,
he took me he I that night I worked they
fired the B camera crew.
>> Wow.
>> And they turned and said, "Do you want
to you want to take the job?"
>> To me, full time job.
>> I think I've seen Hollywood as a
filtration system.
>> Are you going to be on our team or not?
Is basically kind of how they treat
that. And and I guarantee you, man, the
devil is pretty smart.
>> And and you know, it's hard it's hard to
say if he orchestrates all that or if
it's just circumstantial, but either
way, it's like There are some things
behind the scenes there. I'm sure
>> the devil has a version of Providence.
>> Yeah. It's like, you know, the when I
first moved to Hollywood before I got
into the production thing because Yeah.
Like you, I went like all over the
board, you know, like tried acting,
tried modeling, tried all these other
things. And one of the first modeling
jobs that I got um was this thing about
boy bands. They thought that I look like
Justin Timberlake or something like
this. And so, so it was in this magazine
and the photographer was super famous
and and the wardrobe guy comes over and
hands me a t-shirt of Jesus Christ being
crucified on his head.
>> What?
>> Or a crown of thorns on his head. And I
was just like, out of all the guys that
you could have handed this to, you're
handing this to me, like someone who has
had a past.
>> And I was just like, you know, and
there's golden chains and junk around my
neck, you know. It was just like it was
like it was like kind of my problem with
what like Kendrick Lamar, right? Like
you know you put a golden or a
diamondstudded Tiffany crown of thorns
on your head. I have a problem with
that. That's a slap in God's face.
>> Well, maybe God allowed you to have that
t-shirt to give you a wakeup call, you
know, like this is what it's about.
>> That could be as well, you know.
>> Didn't you also did do some work for
Steven Spew? Like something small.
>> Well, yeah. You know, I I know I Yeah.
I'm my IMDb.com. I have that's that's
the industry resume. you know, you used
to like make out your type, you know,
email them and now you just you just
it's online. No, you don't have to send
resumes anymore. It's great. So, I have
a
>> most of my credits are on IMDb.com and
yeah, there's a little I was actually
only there for like four days.
>> What What did you do?
>> Oh, we just did uh I was I was on X
camera and you normally Spielberg is
very famous for doing all the shots
himself. Like there's really not a
second unit on Spielberg. I I don't
think I don't think that's changed.
>> He's in control though. He's in control
and he's got his guys and it's a tight
group and they're very good technicians
and everything but I because Yannesh
Kaminsky his cinematographer went to
film school with the cameraman that I
knew at the time another Polish guy who
never made it to that that level but he
was you know they're film school buddies
and so he you know Yannish said you know
we got to do some ex camera second unit
kind of stuff you know come in and start
shooting for us
>> and that was the cameraman that I worked
with so he brought me in as his
assistant his first assistant so I got
to work on like X camera for like I
don't know like like within a span of a
week four days or something.
>> Can you say what movie?
>> Oh, it's uh artificial AI artificial
intelligence.
>> How crazy is that movie in terms of what
we have today?
>> Oh man. Yeah.
>> No, it's crazy.
>> She probably has no idea what we're
talking about.
>> I I Googled it after I You told I
Googled it, but I've never seen it.
>> You wrote
>> I don't know if I ever saw that
>> really.
>> Yeah. I don't remember.
>> There's there's there's probably like
three or four quick shots that I did
that are in the movie that just fly by
like a little insert kind of stuff.
That's all. There's some special effects
stuff, but that's it. That's all I did.
>> Of all the people in the, you know, you
could talk to a lot of technicians in
Hollywood. There there's a few films
that come up more than any other
>> and you know, Kubric's up there, but
Bladeunner is probably one of the most
mentioned cited films of inspiration.
>> I remember watching that as an early kid
too as well and and being just
fascinated with the futuristic ideas.
>> Bladerunner is pretty gnostic, isn't it?
>> Very.
>> It's very Luciferian.
>> It's very Luciferian. Yes. And I
recognize that now. And I just it makes
me sick because you know that's the
thing about stories you know stories you
know it's
if we ask somebody like would you be
willing to go to like an evangelistic
meeting run by Satan would you want to
go to that meeting?
>> Absolutely not.
>> Absolutely not. No no one no one most
people would say well ne never you know
but I mean every time you turn on the
television you listen to the radio you
put you're actually going to an
evangelistic message. That's what it is.
I think people need to look at look at
him like that.
>> I really do. Yeah.
>> Is this holding up the principles of
God? Yes or no? Right? If it doesn't
speak to the law and the testimony,
there's no light in that thing. Right?
And it's like how much darkness has been
spread on our world simply because of
these stories.
>> And it's like if you like if you look at
what the Bible is, what is the Bible?
It's really a collection of stories.
>> I mean, that's really what it is. And if
you watch enough of those stories over
enough time, you will eventually be
either influenced or whatever over that.
And I think the same things with
Hollywood. Devil's really smart. He's
looking at that going, "Oh, wow. A lot
of people are learning from that book.
I've got to
>> go." It's like everything else. I mean,
this is something my dad said, which I
always remembered. It's like, you know,
Christ is is like the light of the
world, and Satan can't extinguish it.
So, what does he do?
>> He just lights tons more lights.
>> Yeah.
>> So, how do you know which one is the
right one? You know, it's the same with
stories. The Bible is the real story.
>> Invent millions of stories for people to
consume so that they never find that
one.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Very true.
>> Yeah. In Revelation 12:9, it talks about
the great dragon who is the serpent, the
devil, Satan. He deceives the whole
world, right? He was cast into the earth
and his angels are cast out with him.
So, there's this whole team there with
this with their leader set to try to
deceive the entire world.
>> Yeah. Yep. And the whole thing is very
interesting to begin with because it's
all smoke and mirrors.
>> It's all like, you know, people
pretending that they're not that person,
they're somebody else, you know. The
whole thing is just like wrapped up
around this sort of art of deception.
And they talk about it like that. You
know, it's it's an art. The better you
can hide these things.
>> Yeah. I mean, that's that's the thing. I
mean, as a technician, as a as a
filmmaker, as a crafts person, I mean,
that's that's the greatest pride you can
possibly have is that you pulled
something off. You you executed a shot
or you, you know, like everybody has
their specific jobs. I remember working
with, you know, guys that do atmosphere,
special effects, guys that are really
good at like smoking up sets and really
keeping the levels and stuff. It is an
art form. They have the huge tubes out
on set on location at night and all
that. And it's like they have so much
like you know if they if something goes
wrong they're crushed. Oh yeah.
Everything is about working towards what
goes into that frame and that frame
takes somebody into another world. Yeah.
And I thought so much of my energy, so
much of my life, so much of my blood,
sweat, and tears, the sacrifice to my
own salvation, the sacrifice to my
family, my relationships, everything was
on the altar to make movies.
>> Yeah.
>> And I was like, this is this is out of
balance. That's
>> true.
>> Yeah. It reminds me of that scene. It's
kind of funny. That scene from Elf, I
think it is. Well, Pharaoh, he's like
looking at the guy's playing pretending
he's Santa Claus and he tells him, "You
sit on a throne of lies.
>> Just cool it, Zippy.
>> You sit on a throne of lies. Look,
>> I'm not."
>> That's essentially what it is.
>> He's throwing a joke.
>> Sitting on a throne.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. You know, it's interesting. A lot
of times people think that, you know,
people in Hollywood are all kind of evil
and they all know what they're doing. I
think most people don't realize what
they're participating in because I've
seen the videos where people break down
>> you know you not I mean but other you
know they're looking for the occult
they're looking for Satan they're
looking for something and it's true that
most people don't really know what
they're doing.
>> Never thought of it like that.
>> No there's churchgoing people in the you
know maybe not Adventists but you know
there's there's Catholics and
Presbyterians and Baptists and
>> and evangelicals that are working on
these movies and they think you know
that there you know that it's all good
but they don't realize what they're
putting out.
>> Yeah. Not that I'm promoting um CS Lewis
by any means, but he made a comment that
was kind of interesting. He said,
"Behind every metaphor is reality, a
reality."
>> Yeah.
>> And it's like, yeah, there is some
reason why we're telling these stories,
right? you know, and it's like you're
either really I mean, I think when you
read the Bible as well, like um you
know, for God to look at somebody's life
like Moses or you know, and anybody
that's like a Christ type, it's because
he's seeing the life of his son in those
people, the same actions that they do,
right?
>> And so I think the devil, you know, is
like mimicking. He's putting out these
lifestyle modelers basically, all these
movies and everything like this. And
then as people mimic it, it's like, see,
no, that's that's my child. I had a
Miami Vice outfit when I was in grade
school. I was dressed like Don Johnson.
>> I bought a fur coat and wore it out in
public because of Fight Club.
>> Like
>> you've told us this before.
>> I should have my head examined.
>> I know. Well, that's but that's what
happens. It becomes your inspiration.
And the music business did the same
thing. You know, the music exposure to
music and and and I I wanted to make
music videos. That's what I really
wanted to do besides making, you know,
movies like Kubri. I wanted to direct
music videos
>> which is a miserable uh thing to work
on. many times. I did a few.
>> Yeah,
>> because they seem like they would be
like super cheap and expect a lot.
>> Yeah. Well, yes, exactly. In a very
short amount of time.
>> Yes.
>> But if you got to to the top, I know
people have thrown millions in a couple
of
>> I don't know if that's so Well, I don't
know if that happens as much so much
anymore, but
>> MTV just seemed like it lost
>> lost that art.
>> So, 14 years, you're on the way up.
>> 14 years I'm on the way up. Yeah.
>> So, did it start going down?
>> Yeah. So,
>> or did you just eject?
>> See, if I was a kid and I was looking at
all these pictures
>> that looks like a fun career.
>> Yeah.
>> And and I think that that's the that's
the picture that people get. Look at
these guys. They're just having fun.
They're playing all day long. And you
know, it's like
>> you don't realize you're on you're part
of an army.
And what side is that army on?
>> Spiritual warfare.
>> Yeah. As much fun as this is, of course
the devil's going to make
>> I worked with an Israeli director. That
movie that was in Utah that I did with
John Ritter, I showed you the pictures
earlier in the fire ring of fire pit,
fighting pit or whatever it was. That
was an Israeli director and it was like
he ran the show like it was a military
outfit and that's how he talked and
because he was Israeli. It was like
they're all trained and they all have
military experiences and it was like
that was the way it ran on set and
there's a lot of old school guys that
run it like that too. It's very very
chop chop. barking and angry and yeah, I
worked for those.
>> Yeah, I did too. I worked actually for I
actually worked briefly with John
>> Landis.
>> Who's John Lannis? He's like a famous
director.
>> Jan Lannis is f He did a lot of music
videos. He did the Twilight Zone movie.
Famously, somebody died on one of his
movies, too.
>> Really? Because it's a horror movie.
>> It's a horror movie. Yeah. Twilight
Zone. I worked with Michael Man, too.
And that these are very strong, let's
just say it diplomatically, very strong
personalities that don't suffer. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Fools or mistakes.
>> It's true.
>> Yeah. So 14 years, I mean that, you
know, my career shot up. I was working
on this TV show. It was syndicated in
about over 170 territories. And so it
was, it's always on somewhere probably
in the world. And, you know, I just
continued on. And after the end of, you
know, that eight-year run, I was just
totally totally burned out. And
>> uh, are you a family man at this time?
>> I'm a family man at this time. In fact,
what was happening is that my my kids
when they would see me on Sunday night
before they would go to bed
>> Mhm.
>> they would say, "I'll see you again next
weekend, Daddy."
>> Wow.
>> Cuz you were just never home.
>> I would I was never home. I mean, a lot
of time I mean, sometimes I would get
up, you know, at like 5:00 in the
morning so I could at least go to the
gym or something in the morning and then
go to work. But even if not, I'm still
getting up like 6:00, 6:30.
>> I'm out the door before they're awake.
>> Monday night, you know, we come home cuz
we worked 14 hours the first day of the
week. I'm coming home after they've gone
to bed and next thing you know I' I've
completely met there's a turnaround
time. So the next day I'm getting up
after they've gone to school
>> and then I come home at 4:00 in the
morning on Saturday morning
>> and I sleep till 4 in the afternoon
>> and I don't feel normal or right. I got
to like decompress and everything and
they kind of see me crawl out when sun
goes down almost like on Saturday and
they get Sunday with me a bit and
>> yeah it's wild. I don't think people
realize like how hard these people
actually work. I mean when I worked in
Biggest Loser it was up in um Ventura
and I lived in Hollywood. So I mean the
distance between that two is what an
hour or two maybe sometimes in the
middle of the day
>> and and when we would have these long
shoots I mean it's 12 hour days and then
you tack on one or two or three hours on
top of that and it's like you same thing
saying I would literally go home lay my
head down pop back up go back to work
and you live like that for
>> you live like that forever and the thing
is what ends up happening is that you
know the family
>> that you live with at home becomes like
you know there's a that grows because
you're just not around. And then you end
up spending so much time with people on
a movie set, they become like your
family on the set,
>> right?
>> With all the dysfunctions, too, because
you don't necessarily get to pick who's
there with you, right? Cuz someone else
hired them. So, it it has this weird
dynamic of shifting your life to a set
life with a bunch of other people.
>> You're fed there. You're, you know.
>> Yeah. Especially if you travel and go on
location, you know, it's a whole
>> Do you think that's one of one of the
reasons why so many celebrities get
divorced actors and, you know?
>> Oh, yeah. 100%. Yeah, you know, I've
seen some things that I, you know, wish
I'd never seen happen. I mean, I I spent
>> I spent six weeks in Las Vegas on a
movie once, a Kirsten Dunce movie, James
Khan, Kristen Dun, and we did it and it
was all shot at night because the
casinos are all open all the time, but
at night it it's the crowds go down. So,
we shoot at night
>> and
>> so the night just the night life in
Vegas all night every night for years. I
mean, and that's that's something I I
learned I learned a lesson about
addiction
um on that on that experience because
there was a time when we were working we
were working at a strip club
>> and
>> filming at a strip club
>> filming at a strip club. No, my very
first movie we were we we had a strip
club scene in I mean how many times I've
had a strip club scene in a movie that I
worked on. Why?
>> Because if you have that in the movie
there's a likelihood that someone will
watch that movie because there's going
to be some nudity or something anyway.
We're shooting at a strip club in this
movie and we finish I don't go what is
like 4 in the morning or something and
we're going to take shuttle vans back to
the back to the hotel
and I'm staying there late because we're
still wrapping up the film. I was the
first and I was sometime doing some of
the second work but I was kind of doing
both of it but I was there to the end
with the camera crew wrapping up the
truck and sometimes that's the last
thing when you shoot film it's one of
the last things that gets shut down
because you're ting all the film doing
the film report getting out to the lab
and I'm there waiting waiting and the
last band kind of goes it's going to be
a long time before it makes its round
back and the first ad is still there
with one of the back with one of the
smaller you know actors that hardly has
any lines kind of like a semi- stunt guy
and they're there and I say hey we'll
give you a ride back to the back to the
hotel and he's got a Porsche. He's
driving his Porsche to set. So, so he's
in the he's driving the Porsche and the
actor's sitting in the right and I'm
stuck in the back licking this little
part of the not a big
>> and it's like and as we're started to
grow these guys start talking. This is
such a weird thing that happened. These
guys start talking and they both somehow
realize that they both like to smoke
crack.
>> Oh my.
>> And that they were recovering, you know,
they're recovering addicts. But they
started talking and that they both had
been crack, you know, smokers. They
started talking and they they jonesed
each other up to the decision where they
were going to go score crack right now
with you with me in the car.
>> Even though they were like
>> they have gone through rehab. They were
going to now they're not going to do
this anymore. They they've turned but
they they just and I saw I learned
something from that. It's like
>> somebody when you hang out with somebody
that has a weakness like yours,
>> it's very dangerous. So the company that
you keep when you're trying to if you're
you know you don't go to the bar if
you're trying to stop drinking. you
know, you don't play video game, you
know, you don't hang out with someone
who's going to play video games all day.
If you're trying to cut back and you
say, "I don't want any more video games,
you know." So, I I that was a very
important lesson and I I I just said,
"Can you please just take me home
first?"
>> Yeah. Wow. You know, and and I identify
with this so much. I mean, mine when I
when I got working in ministry, I was
both feet in the world at one time. I'd
gone to my bosses and I'd asked them for
a Friday night to Sabbath off. They gave
it to me. I was shocked. And um we were
shooting the last show in Scottsdale,
Arizona. So I was flying home in the
weekend to be with my wife and um then I
just fly back in the in in the day and
and tech the show. And so um in between
that time, I'd been sober, clean, not
not messing around with any of that kind
of stuff. And the the the night of my
wedding anniversary, I needed to get on
an airplane at 600. We we got done
filming at 3:00. And so I was like,
"What am I going to do for an hour or
two?" You know, it's like, "Oh, I'll go
hang out with the crew." And I went
there and everybody was like doing drugs
and and it was asked of me and I just
said, "Okay, cool. I got to I got to be
up anyway. I'm not going to go to bed."
And and that pathway even though I had
had not participated in that for many
many many years or
>> year or two and and I said yes and I
never actually went through with it as I
was going. Um somebody you know kind of
made fun of us
>> and and that starkly kicked me out of
that and I just ran out of the room went
back to my hotel room dude crying. and I
went home to my wife and I went, "I
almost came home to you like on our oney
year wedding anniversary and
>> you know, it's just like awful."
>> So, yeah, you you're just around these
people and these are pathways that you
make in your brain. And that's another
thing, too, is it's like as people have
this glamorized view of what Hollywood
is, you don't realize that the crew and
everybody else, I mean, what experience
do they have? It's like you're in this
petri dish of people with messed up
morals.
>> Absolutely. The very first movie I ever
worked on, we hung out every night after
work and everyone was getting stoned.
>> Yeah. in Australia.
>> Yeah.
>> And it was in drinking there till left
to drink
>> and drinking drinking stone. The first
movie I ever worked on and I didn't
really participate in that too much but
I just was just in that atmosphere but
it continued through my career when I
worked on Robbery Homicide Division. Tom
Seismore was the actor on that who's
passed away since then.
>> There was a guy assigned to him to try
to keep him sober.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh wow.
>> And you know and we I you know I had
experiences with Tom and others together
and just you know just the the drugs.
There were a lot of drugs on on that
show. A lot of drugs. And it it was on
many shows that I worked on. And it the
people that I hung out with you, they
became like my buddies, you my film
guys, my colleagues, you know, you know,
we'd end up going to the bar. We worked
in New Orleans. We went out every single
night to the bar. Every single night
working in New Orleans for a month.
>> Yeah.
>> It's just
>> it changes you. you like and I this kind
of goes to like something that happened
to me that really got my attention
towards the end of my time in Hollywood
up before I left. You know, I was so
inspired to to make music videos and I I
there was certain videos that I I just
really attached to when I was a kid in
the 80s and so I was I was had my iPad
and it was in the bathroom and I was
just, you know, I was at the counter or
something at the sink and I was just
flipping through and I and and a YouTube
video came up and it was the music video
that I used to love as a kid. I was
like, "Huh?" So, I just watched the
video
>> and as I watched the video,
>> something weird happened. I I I saw
myself
>> as I was when I was a kid. I saw who I
was in the 80s. I saw, you know,
innocent, you know, wideeyed, just the
world's ahead of me and my dreams are
just, you know, everything is within
reach and just before me. I saw myself
in that moment. And then then God showed
me who I'd become
>> standing in my bathroom with everything
in my history that I just done in
Hollywood over the last how many, you
know, few decades of my life.
>> And I was I was I was gutted. I I I
wept.
>> Wow.
>> Because I realized how far I'd fallen
from from where I was. And I never
thought, you know, I'll give up the
Sabbath. I'll just walk away. I mean,
I'm not going to leave God. I kept
praying to God. I kept talking to God
through all that many those years, you
know, maybe less towards sometimes. But
I always was like, I'm not leaving God.
I'm just sort of going and checking
things out and living a little bit and
and over decades, you know, you just so
far and the influence around you cannot
help but being changed by the
>> by what's around you.
>> Doesn't the Bible say bad bad company
corrupts good morals? Yeah, it's true.
You're a product of the people that you
surround yourself with. And and and
that's why I mean, you know, I've got
teenage kids now and so, you know, we
have lots of discussions in in our home
like, you know, make sure you choose
your friends carefully, you know, and
wisely. Like, you hang out with the
wrong people.
>> It's a matter of time you're going to
start participating in whatever they're
doing.
>> Mhm. and break
you Jacob
and he formed you Israel.
I will make him a pillar in the temple
of my God and he shall go out no more. I
will ride on him the name of my God.
Be strong in the Lord and in the power
shall renew strength. We shall mount the
demons like he shall run another
but by every word that proceeds from the
mouth of God.
[Music]
So, it was around this time with my kids
being like their childhood evaporating
before my eyes. I'm never there. The
experience of realizing how far I'd
really fallen and just the exhaustion. I
thought, you know, we we we made a plan
to move to Canada
>> to get out. And I never thought I would
come back to church and do ministry. I
never thought that in a million years.
But I just wanted to get out of LA. I
wanted to get out of that pressure
cooker. wanted to get out of the all the
bills and everything and the amount of
money I had to work to keep everything
going because it was expensive and I
just I just wanted to get out and you
know we we decided to move to Canada.
But as we were getting closer to leaving
to go to Canada I I started to think
about some of the things that I knew
when I was a kid and I I actually got
this this urge to start reading the
great controversy.
>> Not with thinking I was coming back to
church just because I was curious. I was
thinking about the big picture in life.
So I was sitting on my camera. This is
like the last three episodes on Castle
at the end of that show. Like the last
three episodes. So there's a lot of
times between between setups, right? So
sometimes I'd have to s I could be
sitting at my camera and you know the
sad thing is you took you took a picture
of of a crew right now. I mean it's
probably still the same today. Most
people are on their phones when there's
a chance to look at their phones. So I
would use that time to start reading the
great controversy over again. And I read
it sporadically. I jumped all over the
place. I think I started with the origin
of good and evil. I started with that
first, but I just jumped around. And as
I was reading this, we were shooting
this episode where the main character uh
opens up a private eye office, a private
investigative office, and he he has this
u this it was this set that um was like
a New York set. It was supposed to take
place in New York. And and there was
supposed to be a wall. He's renovating
his office and they they break through a
wall and they find out that it's a fake
like there's something behind it and
there's like a room that's been sealed
off for many years and it turns out to
be a murder mystery that's in in the
story. But in this room was filled with
all these occult objects, all these like
satanic imagery like Baimett statues and
daggers for like sacrif was really dark
satanic imagery and I'm sitting here
reading
>> the great controversy reading you know
the origin of evil to fall from heaven
on set and and I and I and it I was we
were doing these handheld POV shots and
I've got the camera and the director is
standing next to me with a flashlight
and he's you know we're just doing the
the POV what what does the actor see and
so I'm panning the camera around like
you know landing on all these on all
these things
>> and are there things that that he wants
to put in the shot? Like he wants you
>> and he wants these shots because it's
like it's his POV when he walks in his
room. How creepy it is. What's he
seeing? There's a creepy satanic statue
there. There's this, you know, and I'm
thinking I'm doing these shots. I'm
looking at these things. I'm reading
about this and the great controversy.
It's like, what am I doing? What is
really on the insides of the walls of
Hollywood?
>> Yeah. I'm telling you, I worked on a um
music video, probably one of the only
music videos that I was actually in. And
on set uh lunchtime, I was like just um
walking around eating lunch and stuff
like this. And I was looking at the
table. They had this like table with a
bunch of TVs and stuff like this all on
it. And there was film strips like like
an actual film strip that that was
spread out all over the table. And so I
went and I picked up the film strip and
I looked at it and I was like,
>> that's Jesus being crucified. And I went
down the film strip and I just went,
"What in the world?" Like no camera's
going to see that. no reason to actually
have that there on the set other than
like somebody had to say, "I want to
bring a a film clip of Jesus being
crucified and I'm going to put it on
this one." And this band was very
satanic and and at that point I just
kind of stood there and I just went,
"Wow." But that wasn't enough to kick me
out of the industry.
>> It was not. Well, you know, you've done
some stuff on Disney, right? I know
you've done some stuff on Disney. Okay.
I did a Disney show because my when my
son was born, my second son
>> was born, um I wanted to be home at
night so I did a kids show because you
got to wrap the kids early as you. So I
was home every night at 6 o'clock. So I
did a TV show for Disney that was, you
know, like a Saturday morning show.
>> Mhm.
>> And we're working on it and I just
noticed a lot of little details that
they were putting in it, whether it was
script stuff or whether it was the names
of characters. They were like
referencing like like gay culture, but
the the things like even the wardrobe,
some of the actors would wear would wear
wear something and it was like it would
cuss like little fine print of of cuss
words like like the f word, everything
all over the shirt, but it would never
resolve in any shots on camera because
it's too fine a detail. But they would
wear that on
>> there's all these little weird things
that they just put in. People would get
kicks in doing it. Get kicks kicks out
of doing it.
>> Yeah. So, so going back to Castle and
like that those satanic props, do you
know why they had all the satanic props
in there?
>> Yeah, it was supposed to be an unsolved
murder mystery,
>> but like why Baomett?
>> Well, I mean, yeah, I it was like some
sort of creepy cult killer or something.
I don't know. I don't remember. But it
was it was but to me it was the idea
that it was like inside the walls,
hiding there all the time, and then you
discover it that it's actually behind
the walls of what you're you're doing.
And I thought that's a great metaphor
for me. I was like, "Wow." Okay. I think
I see what you're trying to say, Lord. I
think, you know, this is not really
>> the place I'm supposed to be. But, I
mean, I still wasn't ready to get out of
Hollywood. Kind of like you, I wasn't
quite ready. So, when I left uh can um I
left Hollywood for Canada, it wasn't so
much to get out of the business. It was
to have the business on my own terms.
So, before I left, you know, years
before I started to think, you know, I
want to make movies that are going to be
wholesome, movies that uplift people,
you know, movies that expose the social
ills, you know. So that was my
transition to try to do something better
was just make better kinds of movies and
not dark movies, not movies with sex or
not movies with violence and stuff like
that. And
>> but that turned into be a dead end too
because it really does because on the
people I was working with nothing had
changed as I got higher and higher
>> and I started to be able to do more
things and I I I co-directed a short
film with one of the actors on the show.
I got stuff in festivals and did that. I
started to meet the guy's agents a
little bit at lunch one time and and
it's like that world was so dark. It's
like them. It's like Entourage. If any
don't watch Entourage. HBO, but that's
so accurate how it is. It's so depraved
and people are so mean and cruel to each
other.
>> Those guys used to come into Crunch. Um
the guy that was like his agent, I
always used to talk to that guy all the
time and
>> you know, it's just like yeah, it's just
weird cuz I watched that whole thing
happen and and and because I kind of
knew them and got to know them a little
bit, the the um one guy that was the
main star, he was ready to quit
Hollywood. I mean, in your sort of same
experience, couldn't book anything,
couldn't do anything. All of a sudden, I
think he was on vacation even or
something something and the call came in
for for the agent. It was like, you
know, he was ready to go. I think he had
started preparing his agents and stuff
like, "I'm done. I'm not doing this
anymore." And they came in for that show
and it totally changed his life. So, so,
um, you know, speaking of how you were
considering doing like more wholesome
movies, before I completely stopped
watching movies, I kind of switched to
what I thought was more wholesome
movies, like true stories, you know,
watching those kind of things or or
like, oh, you can actually learn
something from this. But then I found
out that a lot of actors who play those
roles will still channel spirits and
demons and all that kind of stuff to
play those roles even though the role
was really wholesome. So, I'm like,
great. So, I can't watch that. But what
was your experience working behind the
scenes on those kind of movies? Like was
it like No, it's because you're saying
like it's it's it's the crew, right?
That's
>> Yeah. I mean, you know, I I didn't do
many horror movies. I I just that was
just not something that I I did one
horror movie in Louisiana. The ideas
though, you know, it just it is a very
creepy thing to to spend. I mean
actually know okay I can tell you a a
colleague of mine that was working with
me many years he did some he did some
horror he did he worked on some big
horror movie over the summer you know a
hiatus he worked on some film and he was
telling me that they actually brought in
like something was going wrong on the
set like things were bad things were
happening people were getting hurt they
actually brought a a priest in to
exercise something out of the film set
or away from the
>> well they're making a movie about you
know ghosts and spirits and evil things
like that so they actually brought some
like a priest in to try to protect the
crew.
>> Oh yeah.
>> So that's nuts.
>> He and this guy is not a religious guy
at all, but he was like it was weird and
creepy. It was, you know, so the expert
I mean I worked okay. Uh there's the
Queen Mary. You remember the Queen Mary
down there in Long Beach? Well, I we did
a show down there. We many shows filmed
there. I've filmed there many times, but
we did an episode of Castle there and
some of the crew stayed there overnight.
>> Was that a slave ship?
>> No,
>> no, that was not a slave ship. That was
like a luxury liner for the back in the
day.
>> Okay. Okay. It was kind of like a like a
like a Titanic-ish type thing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, we'd shoot there and and
and people would stay overnight because
we'd be back the next day rather than go
home, you know, just, hey, we'll we'll
give you a room in the Queen Mary and
sleep. And there was always talks about
it being haunted. And some people would
hang out and just look for ghosts and
all kinds of things. And but that stuff
was always around. You know, you talk
about music videos. I worked at the um
>> uh what is the name of that place?
MacArthur Park. There's a hotel there,
famous hotel, MacArthur Park. Um
>> is that down there by the um sort of
white memorial? I guess that's like uh
as you're leaving um down the 10 to go
out of LA.
>> This is the senior moment
>> cuz there's so many locations. It's all
gone.
>> Yeah. While you're thinking about that,
um I worked on a on a show that pulled
into a um a sane asylum old rundown in
Assane asylum that was kind of out there
and and um they were changing there was
a horror film that was being shot there
and our crew was coming in to do
something for I don't remember what show
but um and the changeover there was a
little bit of mix of the of the of the
crew and I had heard at this time that
weird things happen like that on horror
films. So I walked over and just started
chatting with the crews. Anything weird
happened here? And they're like, "Oh
yeah, dude." People walking through the
walls, people doing like, you know,
seeing things that are not there, kids
laughing down the down the halls, things
slamming, talking, voices. And I was
just like, "Oh, wow." Just like The
Shining. Yeah. Yeah. And I think that
they want to scare you. Think about it.
Think about it from a spiritual warfare
perspective. It's in their best interest
to make the hair go up on the back of
your neck. Why do you think your dog
gets freaked out if there's something
like, you know, spiritual happening in
the room? M
>> they know that and if they make you
fearful that movie is going to do
better.
>> Wouldn't surprise me.
>> Yeah.
>> Absolutely.
>> But there is a lot of there there is a
lot of people that are involved in the
occult in the business that are
channeling especially in the music side
of the thing. I there was a hotel near
MacArthur Park that I I've worked with a
number of times. One I was there and
again lighting setups. We had a long
time to wait. I loved exploring places.
I would go and explore all kinds of
places. You in a film you get to go
really interesting places with crew
access you know where you shoot. So I
would just go all up and as I went down
to the basement of this thing as I got
down the gra the graffiti on the walls
just got creepier and creepier and
overtly satanic and there was a music
video shooting down there that day. Oh
>> interesting
>> and it was just I I didn't go all the
way down there because the stories you
know that I would hear that there it was
haunted that things happened to people
when they went down there and this is
where the this is where they chose to
shoot this
>> this music video like they were
channeling it to go there for that
reason for that energy for that vibe for
that atmosphere to shoot it there. Um,
>> that hotel was actually like a Masonic
temple too, actually. Almost. It was
like it was set up like if you ever seen
old Masonic pictures of of like the way
that the architecture with, you know,
with all the symbols and stuff.
>> Check Florida.
>> Yeah. This hotel had rooms like that,
like a banquet room that was like a
Masonic like hall almost.
>> That's interesting,
>> dude. I think I think you guys'
testimonies combined is just showing how
dark Hollywood and the music industry
really is. So,
>> I just think and and I'm sure I
scratched the surface. I was barely um
on tip of the iceberg. I mean, you
probably have a much deeper experience
there rubbing shoulders with all of
these things,
>> but it's interesting for me to hear that
because I've kind of shared with these
guys stories behind the scenes and to
hear that from someone else in the film
world. The film world was the was the
niche,
>> that's what everybody wanted
>> and it was like if you could get to that
thing, but it was very close-knit tight
group and and um I mean Hollywood's like
friend like high school with money.
>> Yeah. if you're friends with each other,
you know, it's like you kind of get
further down the line. And so, um, you
know, when you see and you hear these
kind of things, I think that there's a
reason why that it is dangerous when you
get to those levels because it's so
closed off and it's like,
>> oh yeah, no, it's a lot of skull
duggery. I mean, really, it is. And I
was exposed to some of that. So, as I
was an operator and I started to do more
stuff, you know, in that that level, you
start to interface more directly with
directors, with producers, you you you
know, you're the one of the people that
can probably drive your car to set, you
know, you're just in, you know, you're
you're just more elevated and yeah, you
just make more connections and and I
was, you know, I mean, I was working for
a great cameraman. He made me in a
camera operator. So, people were giving
me favors. I got free cameras. I get
free color timing at the, you know, the
post house for the projects that I would
shoot because I was, you know, I was
being, you know, I was going up that way
and I was make that make those
connections. But,
>> you know what happens to, you know,
people have seen what happened to uh P.
Diddy,
>> Buff Daddy, whatever his name is. And
>> that's really not that uncommon.
absolute abuse
>> because the way that it works in
Hollywood and this is a long
longstanding
way of working in Hollywood is that the
way you control people is you get them
with their vices and you capture them,
you get dirt on them, you get pictures,
you get evidence and you control and
this is how old Hollywood worked in the
studio system.
>> Um they'd keep that actor in their
studio because if you don't I'm going to
release this stuff or whatever like
this. They're basically blackmailing
people who work on their projects.
>> Yeah. Judy Garland.
>> Interesting,
>> right? I mean, she was kind of known. I
think she had a history of
>> Yeah. And she kind of flipped out in the
end there.
>> She did flip out at the end. But see, I
I worked with somebody that that that
knew that worked with Orson Wells.
>> Oh, wow.
>> And Orson Wells had those pictures cuz
he was one of those big studio people.
He had some of those pictures and he
shared them. He showed them to these to
this person I knew and he says, "Yeah, I
know. I saw those. I saw the blackmail
pictures from some of these actors."
>> That's nuts. That's how it works. So, so
what I such a sick
>> what I experienced too with with some of
the people that I I was hanging out with
sometimes um
>> that what they do is they try to find
what your vice is and if you have a
common vice they get you further into
that vice and then they get you into a
situation
>> that could be compromising that they
suddenly have I didn't stay too long
into that situation thankfully but that
was that's exactly how that works. I
know it happens to men and women um you
know probably more so with women just
because the vulnerability um aspect of
that and they're usually typically seem
to be a little bit um younger in age
where the men kind of typically can be a
little bit older but I mean there's very
real world experiences where if you do
those things that they're asking you to
do you get participation in in and
greater and greater things. I had a
friend that we made a um when the Dukes
a Hazard movie came out, we knew the
director and stuff.
>> Seen a movie when I was younger. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, uh in fact, I was really good
friends with with um one of the guys
cousins. And so, uh because he was a
family friend of his, we said, "Let's
make a movie and try to get some parts
in this movie." So, we went out and and
shot on all this stuff. And the lady
that we had play Daisy Duke, she was
kind of this like um good-looking young
girl. and and I can I can remember very
innocent came from somewhere over here
on the on the southern side and then
like went out there and um and then all
of a sudden I saw her sitting down with
some producer people and stuff like this
and chatting and and whatnot and then
she just disappeared and she was flying
around from New York to LA to all this
with all these like highowered people as
their like date for the night and just
disappeared. And so a lot of times
people don't think that that that kind
of stuff happens and it just destroys
people's lives.
>> It's more common than you think.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> You heard of a 764?
>> It's like a a cult, I guess, like an
online cult ring and they were doing
using the same tactic. They would be
very good with technology and they'd
pick on young kids and they'd be like,
you know, I invade their privacy. Hey, I
have this picture that you know you took
on your phone or that was on your laptop
or whatever. And then they would
convince them like, hey, I will release
this to your family unless you do this
thing like unless you kill your dog or
your pet rabbit or your hamster or
whatever.
>> And they would then they would have them
film that
>> and of course capture that. And they
would just have them keep pushing the
envelope, keep going further and further
and further
>> and you know, same kind of tactic. It's
like I have something on you. I'll
release it.
>> And the only way you can get out of that
is you just have to be like, you know
what, I messed up. Go ahead.
>> That's the only way you can be free.
Otherwise, they're just going to keep
you in it and keep pushing the envelope.
>> And you know, in in a strange way,
Scientology works in a similar way with
auditing, right, with their thing where
that you basically go to a person and
confess everything.
>> It's like a lie detector hooked up to
you and you confess everything and they
use that and hold that and they control
you. And so,
>> you know, there's people that are in
that, especially actors that, you know,
want to stay in a certain
>> guarded position with their career. They
have dirt on them and they control them.
>> It's dangerous.
>> So, earlier you mentioned that you
eventually went to Canada to escape it
all. So, you were still kind of working
on Castle. Went to Canada, finished
Castle. What And what what happened in
Canada? What kind of career did you have
after that?
>> Well, yeah. So, I moved to Canada and I
took like 18 months off. I I before I
finished Castle, I went back did pickups
on Castle. It was over. I was selling
the house. So I I didn't work for a few
months and we moved to Canada in August
and I just I didn't work for Yeah. 18
months. I was just so burned out. I just
wanted to go grocery shopping, cook
meals, be with my kids. I just loved it.
I gardened. I started growing tomatoes
and getting to heirloom tomatoes. I was
just like, "This is like so good for me.
This is like therapy. I really needed
it."
>> But it was interesting. I I felt
because my identity was was a Hollywood
my my identity was this filmmaker. This
is what I wanted to do and I I had to
come to the position where I realized I
needed to let that completely go and be
something totally different. But there
was a time when I sort of struggled with
it. I didn't want to work on those
things. I didn't really want to forward
any of those things, but I just missed
operating a camera. I missed doing that.
It was a great job.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> It it was a great job to do. And and
>> you can't say it's not fun. Oh, I
>> Everybody likes doing what they're
doing, otherwise they wouldn't do it.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Now, I So, I I
>> I hadn't moved my membership from the
union yet. I It's still in local 600,
you know, back in the States. So,
>> I made some phone calls and sure enough,
they were able to very quickly, you
know, transfer my membership to 669 in
British Columbia, camera union there,
>> and the phone started ringing right
away.
>> Oh boy.
>> Right away, the phone started ringing. I
was like, that didn't even happen in LA.
I mean, I was working all the time with
this with the one guy in the crew. True.
You're a bigger fish in a little pond.
>> But now I'm a bigger fish in a little
pond and I've got a decent resume and
I've got, you know, couple of decades or
more and I've been a camera operator
for, you know, about 10 years almost.
And it was like, okay, I can work if I
want.
>> So I had some caveats. I cannot work
from sundown Friday to sundown. Everyone
thought I was Jewish.
>> Yeah.
In fact, there was a time when the one
of the producers was going to work on
one of the films that I did or was doing
in the film I did. He he I was hearing
that he couldn't wait to meet me because
he hadn't met another observant Jew in
Hollywood in so long. He's like, "Yeah,
and I'm a 7th Day Adventist." It was
kind of interesting. I had a chance to
talk about that. But nonetheless, I
still went back to set. But they, and
this never happens, right, in Hollywood
where they basically, because I would do
like some SEC, I would shoot the second
units and stuff and extra camera stuff.
>> They would reschedu for my s for the
Sabbath.
>> Wow. which is
>> that's incredibly incredibly strange for
this for the set to bend to your
>> wow and they did that for me on the last
movie that I worked on. But but I I I
was able to get by without breaking the
Sabbath was not an issue for like three
movies, but the last movie that's the
one where it really kind of came to a
head because I had started to go door to
door doing Bible work actually through
my local church and
>> in between shooting.
>> Yeah. Well, it started before I went
back to the set. No, it was before I
went back to the set and I was just
doing that and I was really kind of
going in a new direction in my life.
And then so I I went back to like I just
dip my toe back into that world and it
was just like it was
>> you're in the wrong place.
>> I was in the wrong place but I it took
me like three movies to sort of I mean I
didn't do full length movies. I did I
day played really. It wasn't I didn't do
the whole show
>> but I did that three times and I and I
realized that at the end of it it was I
have to I have to leave this alone. I
have to turn back. I have to find a way
to let go of this identity that I had. I
saw myself as I'm this guy. I'm this
cameraman. I'm going to be a filmmaker.
I had to let that go cuz I realized all
my dreams that's a strange thing to come
to your whole life cuz I'm very
ambitious and career oriented to come
from that from like you know high school
all the way into your 40s and you
suddenly go
>> yeah I'm on the wrong path I have to
throw everything out.
>> Yeah. Feels cool to be like I'm a
director or I'm a worked in all these
movies all this all all this awesome
stuff and and then now it's like people
ask you what do you do? I'm a Bible
worker.
>> I'm a Bible worker. I'm an evangelist.
>> I love it. I'm an evangelist. That's
what I do.
>> But in the eyes of God, that's so
valuable and so precious
>> more than anything else. Humility is one
of God's greatest things, right? It's
the antithesis of pride.
>> And so it's like he wants us to be
humble. I mean, Jesus was the most
humble, right? that that that's why you
know in the storytelling world you have
um like the hero with a thousand faces
that um Campbell written wrote and uh in
there it's this model that basically
every single story follows this model
and it's always like you know you you
have this person who lives in this world
that he doesn't realize there's this
bigger world out there and then he goes
and and finds and discovers like there's
this whole thing that that goes sends
him on this journey and then he goes to
this journey and he has to do some se
sort of sacrificial thing and then he
comes back and and he's the hero or
whatever,
>> but it's like every single story follows
this model except for Jesus.
>> I mean, Jesus is like the one thing
that's just like, you know, this
standalone thing. And even Joseph
Campbell, he didn't know what to do with
Jesus. He was like, I don't know what to
do with Jesus.
>> And so, this is real.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And it's like the point
of that is that that that we in our
human storytelling, we can't even come
up with a story that models this savior
that came from outside. I mean, we're
talking like the king of the universe
with the most prestigious position in
the entire world. Never been never
started. Uh he was always there uh to
come down here to this little muddy mess
and and and do what he did. And it's
like, you know, where are the stories
that that inspire that?
>> Yeah.
>> Was was it worth it to you? Like looking
back now, you've been out in Hollywood
for a few years. You know, there's
there's clearly, you know, you're not
doing the one thing you've always
dreamed of doing anymore. You're now
doing Bible work. You're not making lots
of money anymore. In fact, you probably
make the opposite. Was it worth it to
you?
>> Oh, yeah. Always worth leaving.
Absolutely 100%. I mean, it's the best
job. This is I used to think camera
operator I used to have on my on my my
Twitter which is now X I had a tag in
there which is I have the best seat in
the house.
>> You do
>> because as a camera operator you sit
there at the center of everything.
Everything done on a movie set is done
for the lens of the camera. Right.
>> And and I'm I'm I'm the one operating
framing it and see. And when you used to
shoot film used to see through a ground
glass and you'd see everything through
glass like through glass and it's real.
It's not digital. It's not like this
little crunchy little video camera
flickering in your eye. It was actually
looking out into reality through like a
telescope. Yeah.
>> And so it was like I had the greatest
job in the world.
>> Yeah.
>> And I realized after I became a Bible
worker and I and I sat across from
people even if it was on Zoom and I
watched people's lives being changed by
the word of God.
>> I realized as I'm sitting there, this is
during co and I'm I'm doing Bible
studies via Zoom and I'm sitting in this
chair and it just it dawned on me and
said, "No, now you really do have the
best seat in the house." Yeah. You're
witnessing the word of God change
people's lives.
>> You know, a filmmaker is much like a
evangelist. It really is.
>> Is and and you know, it's like you're
telling the world this vision of this
thing and and so it makes a natural jump
into what you're doing now. Um
>> you're framing the story.
>> Yeah. You're framing the story.
>> But the greatest part about it is is I
don't have to come up with a script.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not based as as a This is one of
the things I really relished when I when
I started doing Bible work and preaching
and doing all that. was because I don't
have to come up with a story or a
creative concept or or express some
inner desire or inner vision that I have
for the world. I literally take
something from outside of myself that's
just already there and I just
>> I present it back to people and it's
like the the it's the perfect it's the
perfect material bulletproof
>> and it's the best the greatest story
that's ever written by the greatest
story writer ever written or has ever
lived
>> that has always lived and always is
alive still like I mean if you ever had
to bring up that concept like so you can
you can uh write this or come up the
story or or you can work on the story of
the greatest story writer that's ever
lived and it's our screenwriter and and
uh you know he's like been around for
like the longest time you'd be like yes
who is he and it's like whoa it's Jesus
>> I wonder if we're going to tell stories
in heaven future
>> we're going to tell our own stories
>> of course we're going to tell our own
stories we know that but but I mean like
are we going to create stories for
people like
>> I don't feel
>> that that's probably
>> safe
>> to do anything like that until while I'm
there because I feel like that will be
the only safe time that I would trust
myself ever again to be a creative
person like that because because of what
I did creatively as an artist. I have
like I'm done with that. I can't I don't
get behind a camera. I don't do those
things anymore because I don't
>> want my imagination, my thoughts, my
creativity or whatever to drew because
what ends up happening is that if you're
not channeling the truth, if you're not
connected to God, you're only going to
be tuned into another station. And it
could seem like there's many different
options on that bandwidth. But if unless
it's that one signal, it's a whole bunch
of other mess and it it will slowly lead
you imperceptibly in the wrong
direction. I don't ever want to go in
that direction again.
>> That's so true. I I I have a question
though. The moment that you left, what
was that moment that you just said, "I'm
done. I'm actually done."
>> Well, I think it was, you know, on the
last show that I worked on. Uh it was um
we shot it in the snow. We shot it
outside and um
>> Oh, you're working with wolves.
>> Yeah, this is me actually doing some
second unit stuff going off and
shooting. I did all these like close-ups
and inserts of hand puppets, you know,
in wolves.
>> Oh, is that not a real wolf?
>> No, that's not a real wolf. That that
that's that's a skinned animal that's
been turned into a hand puppet. Wow. For
close-ups of this. It's called Daughter
of the Wolf.
>> Snap. They do that. I didn't know that
they did that.
>> Oh, yeah. Well, I'm not supposed to show
you this because now you see all the
magic behind the scenes. So, they use
these. This is what made it end up
looking real in the end because they
couldn't get real wolves to attack real
people, right? So, they're doing this
with with puppets and stuff. So, I did
all I did did pretty much mo I did I
think most of that stuff that's in the
movie that's like this I that was the
second unit stuff I did.
>> Oh, wow.
>> All those close-ups and stuff. So,
>> um we were working on that show and I
I've done a lot of like action stuff. I
started working in action movies. I
mean, some of the earliest stuff I ever
did when I my first shows I ever got
paid on, we were flipping, we were pipe
ramping, you know, cube trucks, you
know, cube vans and stuff like that in
down in Santa Monica or in Long Beach.
So, I've been around stunts a lot and
then I've been in some situations where
I was not always very safe and you've
heard people getting hurt. So, I was I
as a camera person where you you're
going to be in the middle of it because
you're trying to shoot it. Well, we did
this stunt flipping a car in the last
movie and this is a um
>> you built a sand or snow jump. This is a
uh
>> Oh,
>> yeah. No, the snow is hiding the real
pipe ramp. So, there's a 16-year-old
stunt girl who's the daughter of the
stunt coordinator. She screamed the
entire time she was in the air.
>> You
>> This is an iPhone. This is not one of
our cameras. This is an iPhone shot.
That's on the side. So, this stunt. So,
I'm I'm one of the cameras that that's
filming this car. Just do that flip. And
let me let me show you where that car
ends up.
That was my camera.
That was exceedingly unsafe for me.
Absolutely. Yeah, it was a little weird.
I mean, they I mean, there's guys around
me. Some
>> people die.
>> That's how There was guys around me.
They had their hand, you know, in my
belt and everything. They were ready to
yank me out. So, I mean, it wasn't I was
without help or safety
>> in the line of hire.
>> But I just thought about this and when
this happened, I was thinking, you know,
this is kind of like this is kind of
edgy.
>> Well, this is a bit edgy. I I I
did get the the heebie-jebies doing
this. I mean, I got a great shot out of
it, but I was thinking, what's what's
this shot worth? Yeah.
>> Is it worth dying in a movie to get a
great shot of a car flipping? You know,
because I was the camera coming it was
coming right at right in this shot,
>> right?
>> So, that was not the only time. So, a
little later in the movie, um they had
me go out and and shoot this um the
snowmobile sequence. They gotten some
actors, some stunt people off of Black
Panther just wrapped and then they sent
them up to Canada and they they were
like doing this this snowmobile sequence
where we're we're doing a chase scene
and there's like, you know, a guy in a
snowmobile with a gun, you know, like
this and I'm I'm being dragged in a sled
behind a snowmobile with the camera
really low. I'm doing these up angle
raking shots of of the stunt woman, you
know, where
>> I can't see. My back is towards, you
know, the road I'm heading and I'm just
shooting back like this and the
snowmobile drivers and we're just going,
you know, full open, full throttle open
down this mountain. This was an
abandoned ski hill uh in West Colona,
>> Crystal Mountain, I think it's called
that this picture. I look at this
picture and I just think, how stupid was
I to put myself in this situation?
>> This is one of the dumbest thing. Oh, I
had a helmet on. Oh, yeah. I had a
helmet on. Great. So, so you're not
going to break your neck when you break
every other of the bone in your body.
>> Break your neck.
>> This is one of those stupid things that
you do sometimes on low budget movies.
And I was just willing. I really wanted
to get I wanted to deliver and give a
really good shot. I knew where I needed
to put the camera. That's is something
you learn as a camera operator. You just
put the camera where it belongs.
Wherever that may be, that's where you
got to put it.
>> So, I was just putting the camera where
it belonged. We didn't have anything
better than this to do it with. So,
we're going down the hill
and suddenly I start hitting these big
bumps cuz none of this has been like run
over before because we can't run over it
cuz we're going to shoot like it's fresh
off the side or anything that went.
>> No, no, no. So, we're just going blindly
into the snow like this and I get thrown
up out of this out of the sled and I
land down with my back towards the
snowmobile that I was doing the raking
shot with and it's right behind me and I
just sat there and I knew the snowmobile
was going to hit me,
>> dude.
>> And I heard it coming and it went and it
it came up behind me and it just went
>> right
>> tapped me below my helmet on the base of
my neck on my bare neck
>> like stop just tapped me.
>> Oh, wow. And it was going full speed.
>> Yeah.
>> But it came to it just suddenly went to
us. I know. I was I was in and when we
went to we went to lunch after that and
I was just kind of in shock after that.
I was thinking
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I think I'm done.
>> Yeah. Did you get hazard pay
>> for that? It's a low budget movie.
>> No, but I was getting the second unit DP
credit, right?
>> So that that seems like it's I mean your
own life is certainly uh worth a lot.
That's only one cost out of all of this.
I mean, earlier I was listening to you
say like you hardly knew your kids.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, what did what did that look like
at the time you were coming out of this?
I mean, is I mean, I'm sure there's
probably collateral damage
>> from that. It seems like a lot of your
life is a cautionary tale of Yeah.
>> A lot of it is a cautionary
>> you chase this dream, but at what cost?
You know, was you know,
>> it's the prodical son story. It's the
story of the prodigal son. You know, you
had everything and you left the father's
house and you went off to find something
better that you thought was going to be
great and you end up, you know, at the
end you realize where you're eating,
where you're sleeping, what you're
dealing with.
>> I mean, my family is the great thing in
my life. I mean, you know, besides
>> besides my relationship with God, I
mean, it's like your family. That's the
thing that God gave us, you know, to
represent him to our children and to for
us to understand who he is, too. And so
that was the big thing that was taking a
hit was, you know, my family, my kids,
and I was not around and and I wasn't
raising them like probably how I should.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. The family unit is there to bring
you closer to God.
>> Yeah. And my family's great. They they
were very patient and loving with me. Um
>> that's awesome.
>> But yeah, I mean that's it. It's a
cautionary tale 100%. So I, you know,
that really was the turning point. I
realized that's it. I I'm not going to
take any more movies. and and later on I
was offered a Bible worker job and I
turned it down at first because I
thought, well, that's just not my
personality to do Bible work. I just
think I just I didn't think it would
work out. They offered it six months
later and I took it and I I I I
resigned from the union in 2019,
December 31st, and the very next day,
January 1st, 2020, I became a Bible
worker.
>> Nice.
>> So, I I had I was convicted. The Lord
said, "You need to cut your membership
with the union. You need to cut that off
completely so that you could never
return and then you can work for me.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> So, real quick before we wrap it up,
you're now also uh a co-host on a
podcast. Yeah. Do you want to tell us a
bit more about that?
>> Yeah, it's the uh the Truth Project
podcast with Matthew Sha.
>> Very good. By the way, we'll put a link
in that description.
>> Put a link in the description. Super
good.
>> Yeah, it's great. Yeah, we're we're
we're having a good time doing that and
there's so much to talk about and you
know, Matthew has a great background
with with current events and talking
about how it fills Bible prophecy and
together we do, you know, I I bring a
Bible study component to it because I've
been working as a Bible worker for so
long and and and also doing evangelism.
So, we have this really great experience
trying to get people's attention to see
that God is Christ is coming much sooner
than we think those events are taking
place and point people to the heavenly
sanctuary and righteousness by faith.
And I really like this the the way that
you guys approach things. You're you're
just gentle the way you talk about it
and then it's like the the the extensive
Bible knowledge that you guys have is
>> Yeah. That's Matthew's like Matthew
really has that that
>> just calm.
>> He's got that Well, you know that radio.
>> We both We both did radio. We're our
personalities are a little different,
but he's got that that that Yeah. Like
you're sitting next to the fire the
fire,
you know, kind of like the ASMR. You
hear like like some commercial and
somebody's whispering in your ear and
all your hair goes up.
>> There's Matthew. Yeah. No. Yeah. So, we
have a good time doing that because
because we really, you know, both of us
were, you know, Walter Vice's ministry
>> was was the video that was the movie I
started watching those videos when I
came to Canada after Total Onslaught and
those that's what really convicted me to
come back to church to start me as me.
That was my and that was the same thing
that brought Matthew out. So, so we both
have an affinity for trying to reach
people out there with this knowledge of
what's really happening in the world.
So, it's it's a it's an honor to be able
to
>> do that kind of a ministry to to help
other people find that.
>> So, now you're showing people a
different kind of behind the scenes
instead of like instead of behind the
scenes and working behind the scenes of
a movie set, you're showing behind the
scenes of current events in light of
Bible prophecy. The real movie that's
soon coming to an end cuz Jesus is
coming back.
>> What a great name. The Truth Project.
You guys got to check it out.
>> Yeah. And I have a website, too, because
I have a ministry that I I I still kind
of have some from before I do the
podcast. continuing in that Sanctuary
Door Ministry. You can find it at
sanctuarydorministry.com.
There's a YouTube channel. It's not very
populated yet, but there's a Sanctuary
Door, you know, channel as well. So,
>> cool.
>> You can find me there as well. Love it.
>> Awesome.
>> Thank you. Very enlightening.
>> Cool.
>> Good to be here. Thank you.
[Music]
Heat.
Hey, Heat.
[Music]